je veux que cette guerre se termine
des informations des services secrets
britanniques à propos d'un scientifique
intéresse le haut commandement américain
un expert en missiles je travaillais sur
une nouvelle arme mortelle fission
nucléaire
ordres du haut commandement de
réquisitionner votre équipe pour cette
mission il est prisonnier des nazis il
nous le faut ces messieurs ont besoin
que vous alliez récupérer un petit colis
pour eux en pologne
on est là pour faire le job et c'est ce
qu'on va faire je vous suis
je vous offre une chance de survie
intervenir espoir de vivre en homme
libre
je sais que votre pays a besoin que
j'aille jusqu'au bout de mes recherches
tous les soldats allemands sont sur le
quai
guaino
[Applaudissements]
le point de rencontre est à 30 km en
territoire ennemi c'est l'arrière corps
d'hitler fabien est la clé qui peut
mettre un terme à la guerre c'est le
moment ces prêts à deux ans